[Music]
there's a little bit about my farm i'm
located in central iowa about halfway to
[Music]
um iowa least four acres of land i have
about two acres in production and animal
production
um i sell maybe december and my main
business is csa i used to do in person
farmers markets i shipped it to online
what i call online farm stand which is
selling directly to my website
and then i do some online consumer
co-ops and increasingly entering more
wholesale
i've been growing for 10 years
i also worked for three years on a
certified organic farm in heritage which
is very close to where i now farm
and i'm not currently certified but i am
depending on certifying this season and
i've always been organically managed
familiar with
organic standards and i've always tried
to follow those
uh just some pictures of the farm and
this kind of shows i'm going to talk
about the different parts of our farm
how we manage them we have high tunnels
that we manage in a certain way we have
uh what i would call more intensive
market garden style beds that we manage
in a certain way and then we have more
uh
what i might call like broad acre
plasticulture that is
that we use so those are all parts of
our rotation
and cropping system
[Music]
this past year
um
so i feel like it's always good to start
off a presentation with some disclaimers
about
what i can what information i can and
can't give you
um so this is just what i've worked on
on farm so far and this system will
continue to evolve without seeing how
much has evolved into 10 years i've been
farming
and so obviously all systems are
subject to revision over time obviously
you can't take the system on one part
and draft it on your own
personality into lots of different
things
and what i found is that
even small variations in location and
climate and soil type can make huge
differences
in whether a production system is going
to work for you or not it's obviously
something that works in northern
minnesota may not work in central iowa
but even something that works in
northeast iowa may not work in central
iowa so that's
don't take any sort of production system
and think well this is it because you
have to then adapt it to your particular
circumstances which are always going to
be different
and then
this is something that i feel like i
kind of
started to learn at this conference and
i'm going to talk about that on the next
slide but
don't let the perfect be the end really
good so i think with crop rotation
especially early on i thought i'd have
to have a set propertization i haven't
had this figured out right away and the
truth is that most most farms do not
have their crop rotation figured out and
that they're changing it over time
and that's not a problem it's like
you're
slowly moving towards
your goals
and so there's always going to be a gap
between your plans and your actual
like you know live reality and that's
not a problem that's just normal
um
and i went to a presentation by k jensen
here that was probably
probably 10 years ago around the time i
was trying to farm
and she mentioned this idea of the
fibonacci spiral so like progress is not
linear we tend to think of progress of
just being a line or we just move from a
to b
but actually if our goal is the center
of that spiral we're kind of spiraling
in towards that goal
and so she gave the example of you know
day one when you start your farm
you're not gonna necessarily have like
written
standard operating procedures for your
workers you know that's not necessarily
a realistic goal for like the first day
you start farming but maybe by like 10
years you might have that so it's just a
good way to think about
especially if you're starting out that
you're not gonna you're not gonna have
things perfectly set from the start
you're gonna have to figure things out
as you go
so i feel like it's always good to sort
of interrogate
the assumptions that we're thinking you
know obviously in organic standards
you're supposed to rotate crops so i
understand that but you know the
question is
and it's everyone's favorite answer
which is yes or no
because i think there's circumstances
where we don't rotate rocks and there
are circumstances where we do and i
think in particular
almost no one rotates crops in high
tunnels even in organic systems most
organic growers i know are growing
tomatoes in their high tunnels every
single year
which is not what you're supposed to do
but they're still doing it and so why
does it still work
well
disease pressure builds up over time so
growers are usually using greenhouse
specific hybrid varieties
that are very disease resistant people
are moving into grafting in order to
deal with disease pressure
um and i've also heard that
you know you can do that for like 10 to
15 years and then after that point it
starts to get more difficult where you
can start to see like depletion in your
soil that maybe is not apparent at first
so um
so obviously the most immediate reason
why we rotate crops is because
because of disease
and soil-borne pest carriers
year-to-year that's at least you know on
my farm that's my my immediate concern
when i'm thinking about where do i put
my broccoli this year it's i don't want
to carry over the black rot from last
year's broccoli to into this year's
broadway
um
and i just want to throw out there that
you know i've been exposed to this
conference and others
about new ideas around
you can actually prevent disease and
pest pressure
um if you build up the biological
activity your soil and you have complete
nutrition for your plants
and i
i think we're all kind of trying to work
towards that but it's not necessarily a
realistic again it's not a realistic
goal from day one to have that in the
situation so we're all still dealing
with these disease and pest problems
and so yes we need to
continue to rotate
um
so i think the big considerations for
crop rotation are
our timing so i think rotating
differently times gas crops so is it an
early crop is it a mid-season crop is it
a lake crop
how far through the season does it go
what kind of window is there for a cover
crop before or after that and how will
that influence
what you can have there afterwards so
for example
if you have an early crop
and then you plant an overwintering
cover crop there
you probably don't want to have another
early crop there in the next year
because you're going to have rye or
something you're going to determine in
the spring so the sequencing of how you
see these cash crops and color crops
and being able to alternate timing
is part of what you're thinking about
with the crop rotation
um and then there's obviously the
fertility the soil the wheat
consideration so um there's the whole
schematic of heavy feeder light feeder
legumes so you have
certain types of crops that use a lot of
nitrogen
certain type of process you can use a
little bit of nitrogen and then crops
that produce their own
and now that's not a realistic rotation
for most of us because most of us are
you know way over representation of the
heavy meters
um particularly we always talk about
processors
always being overrepresented in a lot of
vegetable complications
so we're obviously not going to grow
like equal amounts of each of those but
it's something to think about
um i think of another considerations
that are there's crops that are easy to
eat and crops are hard
so like carrots and onions
our crops are very susceptible to early
deep pressure so you probably don't want
to put those in your medius field you
know you want to think about what was
the wheat seed load like there last year
did i let a lot of wheat seed fall on
the ground that last year probably i
don't want to put my carrots there this
year versus potatoes that's an easier
crowd controlled builds in a little bit
more tolerant of weeds
so those are things to think about
[Music]
so this is a this is a map of my farm
that we
i think this particular map we actually
drew up this past year
and this shows our field system and kind
of how we how our farm is set up and how
we
rotate through these different fields
so
uh just to show you the what's called
the short fuel north shore south those
are what i call the
market garden intensive production type
bed so those are 100 feet long
they're uh the beds are
four feet to four and a half foot on the
center
um
we tend to manage those by hand
generally like in terms of work we do
no-till on these beds which i'll talk a
little bit more about we tend to use the
bcs walk-behind tractor for preparing
the soil
although i am increasingly setting them
up for tractor
um spacing
um and they're bare soils we manage them
as air soil
and then we also grow
crops that are higher value and higher
turnover in those beds
the long field west longfield east and
the far field those are set up
uh for tractor cultivation and they're
set up for laying plastic mulch and so
they're longer those are 265 or 270
footbeds
so i kind of have a hybrid system on our
farm where we have both what i would
call like intensive market garden style
production and we also have what i would
call more like a broad anchor
um
glass culture
tractor rototiller peg system
so as i mentioned in the short beds we
do shorter maturity higher value props
so lettuces
spinach carrots beets
um things that we can double crop so our
goal with that is to get two crops a
year at least it's not free
um
so there tends to be a higher labor
input per crop because we're going in
there and we're cultivating my hand and
we're playing compost potentially
so
there's a higher labor involve a line to
get a higher
higher revenue
in those
in those fields we tend to use compost
as the basis for our fertility so we're
laying a significant amount of compost
and that's part of what we can do with
our no-till trial that hannah and i did
over the last few years where
we actually tested out
no-till management versus prototype
management
and i did that in these heads and so as
part of that we were laying down really
thick layers of compost and you're using
that as the basically a mulch that we're
then planting into without rototilling
um
we usually use overhead irrigation in
this in this section and that's partly
because we're doing a lot of hand
cultivation and if you have irrigation
and you can cultivation it's really
really annoying to have to work around
your irrigation or have to move it out
of the way and move it back
so we moved to doing overhead irrigation
in this in this area
that also really helps to germinate in
sea so like carrots in particular we've
had really
two really dry summers and
both those summers i've germinated my
carrots entirely in irrigation whereas
in the past i germinated those with
rainfall and so that's been a really big
part of being able to control
more of our
seed germination especially in that
summer summer window
and as i mentioned we do we control back
hands we use a lot of wheel hoes we've
set up our spacing so that we can use
different types of wheel hose um
you know so we tend to do things on two
or three rows mostly so that our spacing
is sort of standardized and it's easy
for us to go into the wheel hose and
just will hold the entire field
so with the long beds
uh longer maturity lower value crops
i'm going to show a crop list in my next
slide with potatoes
um
brassicas broccoli brussels sprouts
onions garlic
we look at that as we're trying to get a
single cash crop and a single cover crop
per season so we're trying to basically
rotate cash crop cover crop cash drop
cover crop
and so the cover crops are the basis of
our fertility in those fields we're
looking to use those rather than compost
or something to recycle nutrients into
the soil
um and so we do use plastic mulch in
those fields i don't i'm not set up for
cultivation i don't have a cultivated
tractor
um
i have one tractor that i use
um where the only cultivation i can do
is blind cultivation so it's not very
good for
actually green crops i can weed the
tire traps
between the plastic beds but that's a
big reason why we use plastic mulch
that's not something i necessarily seem
to be
a practice that we use forever but i
have to get to the point where i have
the hopefully
the experience to be able to get rid of
it
in those beds we use drip irrigation
because we just put them under the
plastic bed
we lay them at the same time as the
plastic mulch
and then like i said we'll use the
tractor to cultivate the tire tracks
between the plastic we'll also do those
vultures within them
entire cracks so landscape fabric straw
mulch or we'll use wheelholes
so the picture on the left is our that's
germinated carrots like sometime in
august and so that's our 100 foot beds
you know the more intensive market
garden style production
and then on the right that's um we're
harvesting over winter onions fresher
onions in
june and so there's also you can see
there's garlic and onions on either side
of my workers there um and so those are
the plastic beds and that's going to
take a look at how those two different
types of fields look
so these are this is the kind of the
this is the traditionally then our
process i say traditionally is in the
last few years this has been what we've
rotated through those different beds
so as i said we
cluster crops so we could grow
certain types of crops in the short beds
and then we grow a certain type of crops
in the long beds
um and so as i mentioned the short beds
the emphasis is on shorter season
generally things that are 60 days no
more than 60 days would be you know
green beans
and some of these things are a little
bit longer than that but the idea is
that we could grow two of these crops in
a season
um and then the long beds the goal is
just to only get a single crop per year
remove the plastic and put cover crop
down or have cover crop and then fill
that in plastic
so one of the big changes we're making
this year is we're really tearing down
what we're growing um we're trying to
increase the amount of diversity
of props that we're growing and really
focus on the crops that we feel like we
grow well
have a good demand for them and we can
actually grow profitably because we've
been dropping crops from our acropolis
so the bolden ones and the ones are
still growing
and they're the ones that are not molded
are the ones we decided to drop
and by drop i mean we're just not
growing them at all or we may be buying
them from another producer
who has a better system than us so for
example getting sweet potatoes from
someone who grows like six acres of
sweet potatoes
they've got tractor systems set up for
planting and cultivating they just have
a much better system than us and so it
doesn't really make sense for us to try
to get sweet potatoes given our scale
you know equipment
so that's this is an evolving part of
our farm um
but this is just kind of showing you
what we're still growing and what we
what we've dropped um
it does make crop rotation a little bit
more challenging um in some ways because
we're growing larger amounts of fewer
crops
and so
we've got bigger blocks of products to
rotate through the field versus having
more diversity that we can rotate
smaller groups of crops in the field
but what we're looking at is this is
kind of how i look at crop rotation
we have we have families of crops that
we rotate through and this largely has
to do with disease you know there's a
disease that affects certain families
like for example black rot is a disease
that affects the brassica family it
doesn't affect cucurbits it doesn't
affect aluminum
um so that's largely what's that based
around it's also based a little bit
around
uh fertility for example so like you
know there's
similar fertility needs within the
nebraska family and similar fertility
means within the carrot family
um so that is another part of why those
are clustered together but when i'm
looking at actually making a map of the
field and like where things are going to
go this is how i'm clustering things and
then within each of those clusters i
might say okay the property's going to
go exactly here the potatoes are going
to go exactly here
but
the first step is just kind of figuring
out what block of crops is going to go
[Music]
and i would say
it's more important than the long beds
that kind of rotation
or really mapping that out with the
short beds it tends to be because
there's so much turnover in those beds
it's a little bit harder to have a set
rotation plan for those beds so i still
think that through but it's a little bit
more fluid in those heads
than it is with the long range
so and then just to mention the high
tunnel so
um i have one
30 by 96 high tunnel and so we rotate
that we have basically three seasons in
that tunnel
we have a spring season where we plan
you in the next few weeks
[Music]
typically we plant spinach and lettuce
although we do also um sometimes plant
arugula and kale
and then in the summer we have tomatoes
in there generally just tomatoes i also
have tried other crops in there and they
try other crops in the future but
generally it's just tomatoes
and then in the fall we'll rip out the
tomatoes and we plant spinach and
lettuce and then we generally will
harvest that up through december and
then the spinach will harvest these in
january and february
so that's kind of the rotation that we
have in the high tunnels you can see
it's not a
it's the same props every year and so
part of the problem is with having only
one high tunnel it's difficult to have
an actual rotation um so i'm hoping
over the years to add tunnels and to be
able to do more rotation
and then
having more tunnels would also allow us
to potentially have a fallow period so
for example we could take one funnel
uh let's say they're like three combos
we take one tunnel every year we can
just grow a cover crop in there so to
give it a rest to break up disease
cycles break up with cycles
um
but currently you have only one tunnel
we're doing this
it's working so far i mentioned there's
some pitfalls to that but
i'll kind of cross that bridge when i
come to it so
um so these are the crop families that
were rotating in the tunnel you know
functionally we're really just rotating
lettuce spinach and nightshade and like
i said with the tomatoes we're just
growing the tomatoes in the same
same place
um this is just a
schematic that i came up with recently
to show how we flip the tunnel from
one season to another
so on the left what you're seeing is
this is what it looks like when we have
small we have fall and spring greens in
the tunnel and so
the black
strips are landscape fabric and then the
green strips are the planted bed and
then kind of each row in this
spreadsheet is a foot so you see it's 30
feet
so this is flipping across the tunnel
and so you can see on the edges we have
three foot fabric
along the edges that's kind of a
permanent walkway some growers like grow
all the way up to the edges of the
tunnel i'm six foot eight it's really
hard for me to put right up against the
edge of a tunnel and so i like to have a
walkway where they can walk all the way
around
um
and then you can see we have the four
foot beds and we plant with a paper pot
transplanter and that's how we planned
our lettuce and spinach so we do six
rows on
a four foot wide bed which is about
eight or nine inches between row it's
about as close as you can get the paper
pot transplanter
between
just going down the bed
and then we actually generally remove
the landscape fabrics we just have a one
foot
bare soil bed
or sorry parasol pathway between the
beds that will just wheel hoe for
re-control
okay so that's fall and spring when we
flip into our summer production which is
tomatoes
we roll out landscape fabric onto those
pathways and so we roll it right over
the center of the pathway and so we're
covering that one foot pathway plus
we're covering a foot on either side and
so we're narrowing our beds down to two
feet wide now so two foot wide stretch
and that's where we're planting our
tomatoes
and
most recently we've been planting them
in a single row and doing a dump and
training into a double leader so we have
a single row tomato space one foot apart
with a double leader going to a wire
that runs the wire would run like right
here and right here so right along the
edges of the bed running all the way
down
the length of the high tunnel and so
we're training the tomatoes up to that
wire
um i think that i'm what i'm going to do
this year is i'm actually going to do a
double row of single leaders
because i think i might have
basically i think the system i've been
using is more for a grafted tomato and
i'm not grafting and so i'm moving more
towards a double row single liter so
i'll be planting instead of planting the
tomatoes
right down the center i'll be planting
them like in a diamond style on either
side so they'll be more directly above
the wire
and then when we flip back into fall
production we rip out the tomatoes we
take out the landscape fabric usually we
irrigate
because the soil is quite dry at that
point and it's been compacted from us
walking up and down the pathways
and then we'll broad fork
lay down a bunch of compost
and then we'll plant our our
lettuce and spinach into that and so
we've been managing the
high tunnel no-till
for the last several years but i think
it's working really well
any questions so far about
uh about this or anything else that i've
talked about
we'll also leave time for questions
at the end
i probably like shouldn't be showing
this from a book but i got this from i
got this from andrew medford's book just
to show you this is where i got this
system from so if you're interested in
that i don't know if they have that in
the bookstore but
you can go check it out but basically
showing you how to do this for a bunch
of different crops
but um so why when you say you think
that's for granted can you explain a
little bit more of why
is it the field it's that the tomato
basically doesn't have enough um
doesn't have enough productivity to
maintain two stems because it will go
with grafted varieties it's got much
stronger root stock and so it has a
stronger root system so it can really
produce on two
statins and from conversations about the
growers and actually if you read the
recommendations that's exactly what he
said i just kind of skipped over that
and
so i'm going back to what the
recommendation is which if you're not
grafting do a single leader because the
plant will be able to produce more fruit
on that single
stem
versus if you're trying to train into
two stems you're kind of like overtaxing
the pumpkin it's like my understanding
unless it's crafted so
yeah so when you're pulling out the
tomatoes and then you kind of pull that
landscape fabric off and you're going
back into your fall production you said
you're using a paper pot transplanter
yeah so what are you doing beyond broad
forking to prep the
planting area in a way that's adequate
for the paper pod transplant
so yeah the the sequence is i'm
remembering it correctly the sequence is
we irrigate then we broad fork
and then we
lay down the compost and then we will
either wheel hoe or tilt to use the
filter to basically get enough
um you have to basically get enough
loose soil to be able to run the paper
transplanter and i run the vapor pods
transplanter on the on the
shallowest depth i found that works best
especially in the dovetail system
because if you run it on a deeper depth
of shoe that's just going to catch any
quads that are going to be you know
underneath there
um
so that's worked for us
some sort of tool to
ensure that those paper tops are varied
if you're putting them in shallow as you
are
usually we just we do it as a two-person
team and so
like others run the paperclock
transplant and then someone will just
come behind me and they'll just kind of
kick soil in around there or use their
hands yeah
so that's just what that looks like um
what the
high tunnel looks like with the
landscape fabric with the tomatoes in a
single row we did some inter planting of
beneficial plants of borage marigold
basil some other things in there so
that's interesting but there's some
weeds in there too and we run a double
drip tape
right along the uh the tomatoes and i
just like the double fit that it just
gets more water down
to work with me
and so you can see we use the tama hooks
which we don't actually use that system
to actually like lower in the tomatoes
but i like that for just being able to
get it on the wire easily and then we
use the plastic tomato clips
and we come in and we'll prune the lower
parts of the tomato
um
and we'll prune off any suckers so we're
just training the tomatoes to two and
like i said i'm going to go to just
training under the single deer
um
and then you know we're pruning kind of
throughout the season usually up until
about harvest time and then we kind of
run out of time and stop pruning at a
certain point but it's to just increase
the airflow and make sure that it's not
a jungle in there
um the last farm i worked on we would
kind of stop cooking
in like may and so you would go in there
and it would be like going into it into
a jungle and it would be extremely humid
and hot and covered in tomato pollen
so i try to avoid that but but the
pruning labor
is sometimes difficult to balance with
everything else we're trying to do on
the farm
and then this is what it looks like in
the
spring or fall configuration this is
this this ball um so you can see there's
roughly half spinach and half lettuce
i've got some kale in there i'm gonna
stop doing kale because we don't plant
it early enough to actually get
good yield from that we would need to
plant it
probably in
late august or early september to really
get nice-sized plants and so i plan to
end up planting it too late and these
have small kale plants that they don't
produce but spinach and lettuce work
really well in the window that we make
planting which is
generally we're planting the end of
september or early october so we're
ripping out those tomato plants and like
mid to late september and then we're
replanting in the fall greens in late
september early october and then our aim
is to have greens
in november which is around the time
that we
have to stop harvesting outdoors so we
try to harvest outdoors as long as
possible and then we move
so with your
pathways being so narrow
um
are you
starting at one end and harvesting
down
yeah
no we don't do like the pac-man style or
like plant the whole tunnel out um so we
do have the pathways to walk down um
in this plant the plant grows a little
bit into the bed sort of the pathway and
even though you're not going to walk
into that function of the pathway of the
more like
18 inches you know between plants
um but yeah it's a little bit difficult
with like getting a harvest so generally
we kind of harvest and then we're
dragging the tote over what we just
harvested you know because it's actually
hard to get our toes down the pathway
itself but it is a little awkward we
have hoops in here too and the hoops get
in the way so it's always a little bit a
little bit awkward harvesting in this
kind of style but we want to maximize
the non-drawing area
i haven't yet found the
motivation to try to move towards that
kind of pac-man style which is what that
means is
people plant the entire tunnel
like wall to wall there's no pathways
and then you just harvest your way
through the tunnels you just walk over
what you've harvested and that's the way
exactly is
as many greens as possible into the high
tunnel space
um so some of the challenge crop
rotation i think just growing different
amounts of the different families like
brassicas are always over represented on
those special farms so it's always hard
to rotate frosted with other other
things and not
and try to not grow rosters in the same
spot every year
um and then like for me my production
levels change from every year i mean
part of that is you know
a beginning farm especially you know as
you're growing
or as you're changing your markets
the amounts you're drawing of things is
gonna change and that's gonna that's why
that idea that well i'm gonna have a set
crop rotation i'm gonna use that
well you could have set crop rotation
one year and then your market changes or
your size changes and you're gonna have
to change that
um
and then i think there's always the
unexpected adjustments and it's season
for soil conditions we've got to get
this in right now and so we're going to
plant it somewhere where it maybe wasn't
the crop rotation plant but it's just
because the soil conditions are right
um sometimes you run short on
transplants or you know you've planted
one less bed of something if you have
the transplants so all those things can
change um
and then i think there's always a
question about growing things in blocks
so like all the brassicas grow here all
the albums grow here versus growing them
as a more
heterogeneous distribution so like you
know sombras is here somehow he's here i
think the block system is easier to
scheme out
it's easier to like plan that way
but also you're concentrating potential
tests and disease problems in a single
block like you're making it very easy
for pests to move in and be able to like
move from proper topic all the crops in
a single family are together
um and i'm working in a two-acre field
so it's not as though i've literally
spread things out that much
but even just having something in like
for example
in that map i showed you in the far
field versus in you know the field
that's farther um to the west
i see differences in how like if i plant
my spring cucurbits
in one field and i plant my fall
compared in another field it takes a
while for them to move
from
from crop to crop so for example like
they basically will destroy the
spring zucchini and cucumber talking
about cucumber wheels and squash bugs
and then once that crop is destroyed or
i've ripped it out and then they moved
to the next one
whereas if they were right next to each
other
i don't know if that would happen i
think they would just spread right
between each other
um
so yeah there's probably more to say
about that i think there's also
considerations of you know being able to
interplant with um
beneficials um to break up lots of props
which also can complicate your
propagation
um but these are just some basic
principles that i try to follow so i
mean at the very least you're not
growing the same thing in the same soil
every year
the high tunnel being the exception
um you know at least every other year
better yet three years i think it's a
minimum there's different
recommendations for different diseases
and
different crops you know some people
will say three to five years but in
general if you're breaking up a pest or
disease cycle over a single year i think
that's
sometimes that's the best you can do
depending on how much space you have
um being aware of edges where diseases
can transfer so i changed the
orientation of my fields so they used to
run
um east-west and i changed them to
running north-south and what that meant
was now all my beds for one year ran
across
the previous year's beds and so like
there was no way for me to avoid
growing broccoli where i've grown
broccoli the previous year and so what i
found was that was with a black rock
transfer so the end of the bed where
where like my current bed crossed the
old bed that's where the black rock
showed up first
and then after that year things got
better because like it just was that one
year where i changed the orientation of
the beds
um
and then obviously if you have
identifiable either
or uh pest issues that you know um are a
problem on your farm
learn about the life cycles of those
things it might make sense to for
example with black route it makes sense
to till in your residue
into the soil either that fall or early
the next spring because the black rod
will carry over on the residue
um tillage can also
help with some insects that overwinter
in the soil
so if you till in the fall
that's generally good practice but if
you have a specific problem you're
trying to address it can make sense
um
and then soil testing every year or
every other year is important um
and then you can adjust your amendments
based on the so if that's in the actual
needs of the crops you're drawing so
actually understanding you know what a
could need what do alligators need what
are you currently in trying to advance
your soil based on the needs of those
crops rather than just having maybe a
fertility program that you use for the
whole farm without regard to
the crops you're growing or the
particularities of your fields because i
know each of my fields has its own
particularities one field is kind of
high in phosphorus one field is
generally lower in organic matter so
knowing what each of your fields
what the needs are of each of those
fields you can try to address them
specifically rather than just kind of
using a blanket program to address your
whole phone
so just to talk a little bit about
record keeping and the way i do it um i
come up with a crop rotation field plan
and i just use spreadsheets for this so
i kind of have a spreadsheet that's
similar to that map i showed you but
it's in the spreadsheet form so like
each
row is a bed in that system i think i
have my screenshot of that next
and then i want to have my actual crop
planting field map so this is my plan
and this is what i actually did
um and then that crop planting field map
becomes my historical record of
propagation so if i have ones that have
one of those for each year that i can
look back this is what i plan to wear in
2021 this is home 20 on my team so i can
make actual crop rotation decisions
because if you don't remember where you
planted things you can't actually make
the proper patient decisions
and so this is just what that looks like
in the
spreadsheet so you can see i just
you know taken the columns and merged
them
across the rows and so each of those
each of these columns of the bed and i
have a little code you know for the bed
so like this is
that's long field east between the bed
um and then i've got
this is actually part of my plan for
this year so what prop i'm gonna grow
sometimes i'll also put in the cover
crop that i'm growing in there
but this is the plan and so then i'm
going to want to capture the actual
planting that i did this year because if
i just have the plan and i'm going to
plan for next year
i don't necessarily know if i actually
fall through that plan or not or if i
had to
[Music]
so
my farm is humbling and service and
decor
so this is a picture from our first
second in our second hand
um and
um
yeah so our we have a two acre field and
it's laid out um
in six sections
about
um
can you turn up the volume a little bit
please oh
i think your
um
yes so this is a picture of planting
garlic um so garlic is our our
um
we have six sections we're entering into
year six of our farm so we'll have gone
through every single section
um after this year and then we'll be
re-restarting and next
in 2023 we'll be
restarting the cycle so um
uh allianz is is our first
um
first
section and so we plant our garlic we
plant onions shallots
um leeks
in this section
um it's the least
uh
it's the least number of beds that we
need to use of any section so sometimes
we stick in
um maybe if you want to plant some corn
popcorn or something for fun um we'll
we'll throw them in the allium section
but otherwise we can cover crop about
half half of the section during the year
um
this picture is actually of
our no-till system which we started just
a couple years ago we started
transitioning our farm to no-till so
that means we um
this yeah this year with maryland we
actually put furrows in our no-till beds
and then we covered those
once we planted the garlic you covered
it with samples and that was our method
of
covering the furrows and then we mulch
after that um but yeah our no-till
system is basically complex based we
build up a bed um
we kind of dig out pathways that we can
um
that are that are
permanent and then we can add compost to
the bed and create tilt
and
uh you hear me
um
they've been having problems
i'll just talk really loud can you hear
me in the back
great kind of okay i'll be as loud as i
can
um
yeah uh
i think that's enough on the no-till
situation so
um
alliums most of them come out of the
field pretty early um in in the fall or
late summer
um and so we are then able to cover
crowd almost immediately
um
uh
for development of fall so we either put
in oats and peas
or a rye veg mixture depending on
whether we went to overwinter the crop
oh yes i'm back
so if
if we want a cover crop that's going to
extend into the spring and grow in the
spring then we use ryan fetch and if we
want to be able to work the ground
immediately in the spring we use
something that winter kills like oats
and peas
we also are usually able to get a round
of buckwheat in um which is a summer
scrap and we'll
kill we'll die at first frost
um
we're usually able to get a rabbit
buckwheat in after the avalanche
yes those are garlic's coming up
um so this picture is of our cucurbit
section
um yeah we follow our
alliums with cucurbits
and um
uh
the
yeah this picture is
basically winter squash um will spread
over many beds so we have to think about
what we're gonna do with the ground that
is
in between these um
these rows of cucurbits
um
so that that here this picture is when
we planted a bunch of lettuce in between
was the procurements before they spread
out um so that we could kind of get two
different crops out of the same
same zone
and of course it gets complicated
uh like
we have you have to get the lettuce out
before it starts getting overwhelmed by
the
um by the vines because otherwise it's
really a mess to walk around in there
our next zone is roots so roots for us
include
carrots beets
um turnips so a bunch of different crop
families um the carrot family and the
raspberry family but the turnips are
yeah
and
the um
yeah so that's that's an interesting
thing because the roots are basically
that question is basically about our
the way we cultivate the crops the way
they're grown the kind of season they
have rather than what family they're in
um
so yeah that that's the way we think
about
and this this is our brazilian section
so it's the most full of any of our
sections
we fill it up every year
with cabbage kale broccoli
um
collards brussels sprouts
and kohlrabi uh and so
but i think it's the most beautiful
of the sections
and again thinking about cover cropping
we
basically are able to cover crop size by
bed so
our kohlrabi comes out pretty early in
the season and we're able to put in a
buffy cover crop um there
or we're able to even double crop
kohlraki before we don't have the same
black problem that
yeah so uh we're able to kind of fit
things in and then always thinking when
we plant our fall cover traps
okay
it is our next craft going to need to go
in
in this ring or
can it wait
until june
um and in which case we would plant rye
or
something that would that would really
pump up the organic matter
[Music]
this is a totally messy messy picture um
so our our tomato section
we also include our
our beans in that section because
um
they kind of have a similar season we
want to we want to plant them after all
the insurance rates after the soil's
worked up
um and we plant several different
successions of beans so we've been
figuring out
just kind of trial and error over the
years
figuring out ways to
kind of manage the architecture i guess
of our section
so that we can harvest the tomatoes
easily and the beans won't be too much
in the way
so
yeah we've started kind of alternating
tomatoes and beans
to just add more
variety and more more kind of ability to
move around
in that section
yes and then the final section is our
green section so our lettuce are
our uh
mustard mixes
um our spinach and then we also put our
peas in the green section again because
they kind of match
the timing of beans we
[Music]
as we need
to yeah that's my co-farmer also in the
greens
section
[Music]
yeah and this is just a picture of
buckmint cover crops surrounding like a
weenie parsley patch
um
just
thinking about the yeah the timing of
cover cropping is a really interesting
question that we're always
always working out and making sure
everything is
accessible and that
we can just get as much stuff growing
um as we can
as possible but um
without overwhelming our
our ideals
yeah
and i believe that is it
so
you have plenty of time for questions
yeah how are you breaking down
and your cover crops doing complete
no-till
building
yes so the question is how are we
breaking down cover crops especially
when we're doing no-till
agriculture
um so
um
a number of different ways we've tried a
number of different ways so we've tried
just like pulling them out of the bed
like leading them out um which is
is not actually as bad as it sounds um
but
it takes a lot of time um
the other
big thing that i think both jordan and i
are trying is uh
silent
um and using silent sharks to break
[Music]
oh down yeah so
um
yeah i mean i think the way that i've
done that is
i have a flail mower that goes on a bcs
and so i'll flail mow it
and then lay the blade the tarp down
and
you know we've we've talked about this
and i talked about this with stylish
charts but you don't get all that much
residue breakdown we found that's sort
of how
the charts were sold to us i guess for
something new because you get a lot of
residue breakdown but i find that's not
so much the case it just kind of kills
what's there and it will start to
decompose a little bit
i'm actually interested in
possibly using clear plastic to try to
get more residue breakdown
um but yeah because you don't get the
residue breakdown i think that like for
me if i want a direct seed or a paper
pot into there i need to then like break
that residue off or do something with it
after i pull the tarp off so
um
yeah we
definitely have
just covered the um
the bed with um
with compost like just like kill it with
a silent star
peel the cover crop and then
just cover the bed of the compost and
plant directly into that
and
yeah we don't use a paper fat
transmitter we just transplant by fans
but it works for us
what have you found
for your no cell systems in direct
seating is that something that you find
that you're able to do or is that kind
of uh
do you have to transition more heavily
into the transplant
yeah so my co-farmer manages the direct
seating and she hates using cedars she
just makes a burrow and direct seeds
with her hand into it and so we can do
that in the no-till system no problem
really um what we have
from
um
we actually found that our examination
was best
when
we would make a furrow and just like the
picture with the garlic make a furrow we
could see it into it and then we just
cover it directly with compost and that
wasn't the best germination
[Music]
um it was really just to orient things
more for the tractor because if you have
100 foot beds and turn around doing it
with the tractor is is terrible so it
was just so i didn't have to do as many
turnarounds with the tractor yeah so it
wasn't necessarily like oh north south
is better it was more just because of
the way my fields were oriented
yes the question is what's the weak kill
like with a silent shirt
i mean it kills annual weeds very well i
think the issue is
typically perennials so like we both
have some issues with the thistles
hollywood's and wine issues so yeah
perennials it does not kill perennials
unless you leave it in place for like an
entire season
so but it will kill that very
effectively kills annual weeds
the question is
it will kill the existing growth
but as soon as you pull it off more
weeds in germany
so like i think sometimes in a tillage
situation people will till first and
then put the part down because they want
to like flush the leaves out
um
before they tarp because you run in the
situation when you kill the existing
heat growth but then there's a whole
another generation that's just going to
come off as soon as it's triggered by
pulling off the part
so
yeah and i'll add that we
have a big thistle problem so yeah we
found that our annual weed pressure is
not as bad in an ocean system because
we're using
a compost as a mulch
but
our fissile problem is is hugely just
coming back and so we try to
tarp
kind of any part of the farm that
doesn't have something growing on it
um
in a you know
for like a three week chunk of time or
more
we try to put a tarp on just get those
thistles
stopped for a second
[Music]
i do use dutch white clover in other
parts of my farm and that's one
oh sorry i do use dutch white clover in
other parts of my farm and that's one
that i've seen other people use in that
situation but i've not personally tried
it in my growing beds i use it in my
like tractor pathways like my access
roads
yeah i've also never tried a living
mulch other than once i tried some
clover and um
and a bunch of leaves germinated with it
and
it just didn't make sense that's what i
just wheeled it in
but i would love to figure that out
yes
when you guys use the tarps to
suppress the cover crops
does
the temperature affect the effectiveness
of the heart
if it's early spring
yeah i think there's definitely a heat
effect with the tarp
that can
i think that might have an effect on
residue breakdown potentially although
i'm saying i'd still be satisfied even
in the summer but i think the main way
the tarp works is by excluding light
so i think in the case of the tarp it's
not so much that it's heating up the
soil is that it's excluding light which
that's what's killing things
um with clear plastic it's the it's the
heat that is actually
killing things and breaking down residue
[Music]
so when you're doing your craft
rotations um in the
sections that you're doing double
crochet
you're rotating
at the end of the season right so if you
have all of your brackets in one section
you know
like some of us have longer seasons
so if you're double cropping multiple
times you're not worried about rotating
[Music]
into a different section at that point
you're so you're kind of looking at it
from a season perspective are you both
looking at it that way
in those sections
i definitely am year by year
here and nowhere else on the farm
yeah when the place that i'm double
cropping i'm usually changing families
but my understanding is like i kind of
had i had this question too it's like is
crop rotation always between props or is
it just between seasons and i think um
i don't know maybe best best practices
would be yes between crops but i think
there is some leeway where like yes you
could rotate like you could grow lettuce
twice
there might be reasons not to do that
for other reasons but like you know in
terms of
an overall crop rotation i think that's
mine if you grow to grow things in the
same
you grow the same family in the same
beds same fields in the same year
yeah so you might do multiple crops of
salanova in the same bed or you do i
haven't done that but it's like it's
again like because i want to have
flexibility
if i have to i try not to i try as best
i can to rotate between props as i can
and usually i've been able to do that
but it is something that i would do if i
had to yeah
in your greenhouse when you said after
tomatoes when you go you bring in
a ton of compost
how many yards of compost in there what
what does a tongue mean yeah yeah so um
it's i think it's pretty quantifiable
it's um we usually lay about an inch
over the top of the soil across the bed
surface and we do it we move with a
tractor bucket and then we'll dump it
into it because we can't put the tractor
in the tunnel we dump it into the
wheelbarrows so we line up three wheel
barrels
dump the
compost into those three wheel barrels
and i'm trying to think i have this
written down
yeah i think you're using probably three
to five bucket loads per day
if i remember correctly and in general i
think i've quantified it but we end up
using about a cubic yard
per bed it's in general if we're doing
that thick mulch layer so we get it
delivered
you know 40 basically 40 pound loads and
that will cover about 40 degrees
yeah that's about the rate we're using
to get that one inch thick
like heavy mulch yeah
um
[Music]
the only answer that i know for
pre-wheels is just the row cover
because it was right when you land the
cross you just cover it and
with row cover that doesn't have any
holes in it and that it moves the two
needles
um
i'm actually
trying to figure out
the
problem when we row cover um
uh for flea beetles and it's often on
brassicas that are gonna vote really
fast especially with that hot
um row cover so that's that's hard to
kind of negotiate um
but yeah
my understanding is if it's a flying
insect then unless you're able to
isolate
long distances it doesn't rotation isn't
going to matter for that because the
flea bills are just going to find your
crop they don't necessarily overwinter
in the soil or if they do they'll just
come up and find the crop so that is
less of a crop rotation issue and like
hannah saying it's just more physical
exclusion and i think that's the case
with other pests like cucumber beetles
they're just going to come find your
cucurbits it doesn't matter if you
rotate them
[Music]
okay um it's not really
rotation related but you were talking
about the road cover do you have an
issue with it
blowing off everybody just secure it or
not let it rip yes so how do we secure
row cover
i
um
yeah in my obsession with excluding free
beetles i have
uh gone into burying this the side of
the recover
um
and
uh so just like continual dirt on all
edges of the row cover um and then the
problem is
if it's a ruble or something and i'm
harvesting multiple times
um
actually
it's like putting it back down um under
under that
row of dirt um after every harvest
yeah the other problem with row cover
that i've noticed is that it it creates
this microclimate that's really
kind of luscious and aphids love it and
they get all over the straps and that's
kind of gross
and i have a question for you where do
potatoes and sweet potatoes fit into
your location
we put potatoes in their tomato section
[Music]
um one thing i also want to i don't know
if the person's own room but i was going
to see about how we've done direct
seating with no-till so it's similar to
what i talked about with
the high tunnel where we're trying to
get enough tilt to be able to run that
paper pot transplanter through and we
did have issues where you know the cedar
is skipping so we're pushing a seater
through the soil it's like hitting a
hard hand layer
but this year i switched to using a jam
seeder and it's a lot heavier and it's
been a lot better for no till because it
can just kind of plow through
sections that where earthway is very
light will just kind of skip
so that's one thing i found that really
helps um with direct seeping into a
no-till situation or any kind of
situation where you have
tighter soil or more residue it's just
it's a more robust
there's probably some vendors who sell
that here that you get okay
[Applause]
we broadcast our cover crops
yeah i i broadcast uh with a little like
earthquake chest spreader and then i i
have a cold attacker so i generally will
pack that in or sometimes i'll disc it
in i've also tilled it in too with a
rototiller
um
but uh
it's not i'm not wild i would would like
a better system because there's a lot of
passes over the field it'd be nice to be
able to do things in a single pass
rather than having to
do another pass but
[Music]
do you guys transplant
the okay
is do we transplant into the residue of
the cover crop
um
we would only transplant into the
residue of a dead cover crop
for sure
and we would add um we would add a
compost mulch over it so it wouldn't it
there would be a lot of tilt
of that compost um
as we as we transplanted so it wouldn't
feel like
very residue
before i plant because generally i'm not
using cover crops in those short beds
although i'm kind of moving in that
direction and i have to do similar
things to what hannah's doing like
parking it
um
yeah so the question is how do we get
like brassicas like brussels sprouts or
stuff that has heavier salt stocks out
of the soil if we're not tilling it in
um
and
we have tried multiple things we've
tried just pulling the whole thing up
and
it's it's awkward because it's like
frozen in the fall by the time
hello hello
uh by the time we're pulling the
nebraska's out it's like the soil is
like frozen and it's really challenging
so we we switched to just chopping them
off at the soil level um and leaving
leaving that root system in there to
kind of rot and because we're rotating i
think uh our roots come next after after
our breast and so we're direct seeding
so we just take furrows and
if it has worked out
[Music]
you